في الكويت اصدر مجلس الوزراء بيانا بشان
مرسوم العفو الاميري الصادر عن العقوبه
المقيده للحريه المحكومه او المحكوم بها
على بعض الاشخاص مؤكدا انه على ثقه بان
هذه الخطوه من شانها ان تهيا الاجواء نحو
تعاون متمر بين السلطتين التنفيذي
والتشريعيه وفق الاسس الدستوريه وازاله
العوائق التي من شانها ان تعطل التنميه
والانجاز والعمل كفريق واحد للارتقاء بكل
ما فيه مصلحه الوطن والمواطن
من الكويت ينضم الينا المحلل السياسي سعد
بن طفله دكتور مرحبا بك معي في نشره
الرابعه من الرياض واولا اريد ان اسمع
تعليقك وقراءتك
لدلاله هذا العفو الاميري في توقيته في
ظرفه السياسي الكويت اليوم
العفو هذا الحقيقه يعكس توجهات ونوايا رجل
عفو رجل تسامح نواف الاحمد الجابر الصباح
مع حفظ الالقاب امير دوله الكويت
من خلالها يصل للقوه المختلفه والسلطات
المختلفه التي يراسها جميعا وهو اننا فعلا
نريد ان ندخل عهدا جديدا نغلق فيه صفحه لم
تكن مسبوقه بتاريخ الكويت فيها سجناء
كويتيون لاجئون وكويتيون هاربون من احكام
همم قضائيه في الراي وبالتالي اعتقد بانه
الرساله واضحه سمو الامير بهذه الاشاره
الواضحه التاريخيه اعتقد بانه يريد ان
يقول لها نحن ندخل عهدا جديدا هناك عاد
همم ما اخذ على الحكومه لان سمو الامير
يمارس السلطاته من خلال الوزاره
التي يشكلها سمور رئيس مجلس الوزراء وهي
انه حتى الان مسالتين لم نعرف عن
هما وهي المعيار الذي تم به هذا المرسوم
عن بعض لان ما قال الكل وانما بعد
وبالتالي المعايير يفترض ان الحكومه تبين
هذه المعايير وتبين هذه الاسماء ايضا
لاننا منذ البارحه ونحن نعيش يعني بين حيث
وبيس حول ااه يعني
التواصل الاجتماعي يعني ربما فيها ال- ال-
الصحيح وفيها همم الغير صحيحه ولكن اريد
ان اسال عن هذا العفو وهو عفو امير في
الدرجه الاساسيه والدرجه الاولى الدكتور
سعد لكن هل هو مكسب لبعض النواب في مجلس
الامه ام هي بادره حسينيه من الحكومه
الكويتيه
هذا يستطيع ان يقول بان هذا مكسب لاحد
ابدا هو حقيقه عفو من سمو الامير ويشكر
عليه وليس به غريب عليه حتى ان همم الرجل
الثاني في الدوله رئيس مجلس الامه سيد
احمد السعدون غرد اليوم شاكرا سموه وسمو
ولي العهد على هذا العفو ولكنه متمنيا في
نفسه ان يشمل كافه سجناء الراي وهذا يعني
ماذا هذا يعني بان
العفو همم او هذا المرسوم الذي ستخرجه
الحكومه والوقعه سمو الامير لم يشمل كل
سجناء ولم يشمل كل المحكومين في قضايا
الراي من ناحيه من ناحيه اخرى
الحكومه يفترض ان تبادر وتقول هذه
المعايير وهذه هي الاسماء وهذا هو ما
سنتقدم به من مشاريع قوانين تضمن ان لا
نعود مره اخرى الى مثل هذه القضايا بالغاء
القوانين التي لم تكن دستوريه في العهد
الماضي والتي على ضوئيها تم محاكمه وسجنها
للاسف غير موجوده
في اساس هذا العفو دكتور سعد يعني هي
محاوله لتلطيف او ترطيب او تمهيد الاجواء
اجواء العمل طبعا اتحدث هنا عن السلطتين
بين السلطتين التنفيذيه والتشريحا انت
تعلم بان البرلمان همم يعني همم حل وكذلك
الحكومه الكويتيه تغيرت لاكثر من مره لكن
الانسداد السياسي بين السلطتين بقيه هو
الثابت هذا العفو الاميري هل سيكون هو
الحلقه اخيرا في هذا الانسداد السياسي بين
سلطتين التنفيذيه او والتشريعيه امس يبقى
الحال على ما هو عليه
يعني هذا السؤال بحاجه الى اكثر
من فيه بتفاصيل لكن هذه المبادره وهذا
العفو من الواضح تماما بانه اشاره ورساله
الى ما تنشده القياده السياسيه من توجهات
الى الدخول والولوج في عصر من التفاهم بين
السلطات بناء على الماده 50 من الدستور
التي تفرض ضروره التعاون بين السلطات
التنفيذيه والتشريعيه والقضائيه الدكتور
ممكن نتوقع انه بعض الاستجابات يعني
المزمار عقدها والدعوه اليها خلال الايام
القادمه من بعض النواب في مجلس الامه
ستسحب
لا اعتقد بان ذلك سيتم لانه اعتقد العفو
لا علاقه له بهذه السجوبات يفترض انها
اجراءات برلمانيه روتينيه لكن من يتابع
الساحه يعرف بان كل هذه الاستجوابات هي
وراءها اهداف سياسيه يعني من يعايش
البرلمان والحكومه
ويتابعهم يعرف بانه ما ان يتم الاستجواب
في قاعه مجلس الامه حتى يتجاوز تتجاوز
الاجواء المستجوب والمستجوب لانه هناك
اطراف سياسيه ستدخل في لعبه وصراع من نوع
اخر وهذا للاسف الذي انهكر الكويت وانهك
الحاله والمسيره الديمقراطيه الكويتيه
واوجادنا في هذه الحاله من يعني البلبله
وعدم التعاون بين السلطات الدكتور سعد
تشكره على المشاركه معي في نشره الرابعه
من الكويت المحل الاساسي وزير الاعلام
الكويت السابق الدكتور سعد من طفل شكرا لك